well he is a Grammy award-winning
multi-platinum artist and he's coming to
Las Vegas for a three-night engagement I
actually got to sit down with legendary
artist Maxwell
[Music]
oh gosh it's Maxwell how are you good
it's so good to meet you Mercedes what's
good it is such an honor to talk to you
and just see your smiling face I mean I
swear your voice is it makes me smile
and then seeing you ah how can how can
my day be bad uh I feel the same way
[Music]
if you're back on the road you've got
the night tour how are things going and
are you excited to come to Las Vegas I
am you know I was there just recently to
to pay tribute to the great Michael
Jackson for the 40th anniversary of
Thriller so I uh I can't wait to to go
back you know the win is one of the most
beautiful places and it's an intimate
theater so I'm looking forward to it I'm
just happy that we all get to come back
and and see each other in person and
interact with each other and celebrate
the music that we've I guess shared you
know for most of my career I read
something interesting about your your
vocal warm-ups and I mean obviously
there's a lot that goes into it but is
it true that you eat a big bowl of pasta
before you say well I had to stop that
because you know it was starting to show
um but I yeah I kind of like fettuccine
um you know but yeah just like uh stuff
that makes you know stuff you know
I guess this is going to be a very weird
word to say it could be a meme in itself
but just moist you know what I mean like
you just want to be you know you know
not sounding like how I'm sounding right
now no I totally get it worst word ever
moist but I totally
the worst weirdest word is moist who
made it up and why does it sound so
appropriate to its weirdness we're
excited uh you're doing a three night
run over at the encore theater at Win
Las Vegas and you mentioned it before
intimate room it's a beautiful room the
sound in there is insane but when you're
not performing what are you gonna do in
Las Vegas what do you like to do when
you're here well it's funny I've become
like such a huge fan of hacks you know I
don't know if you know the TV show yes I
love that show it's like Jean Smart is
like a god to me you know she's her her
timing her wit and uh and just the whole
show so you know obviously it starts in
Las Vegas so I think I might do all the
stuff that I saw in the first season of
hacks well not all of the stuff because
sometimes it's a little crazy but um but
I made five you know into California or
you know go somewhere here and there
um to beat the heat because yeah it's
got to stay cool keep those vocal cords
moist right
this is going to be part of my Wikipedia
[Music]
you can check out Maxwell's special
engagement at The Encore Theater
starting tomorrow night Friday and
Saturday night tickets are still
available through Ticketmaster it seems
like such a nice